SPEAKER: In this
video, we're going
to walk through creating a
self-serve online Google Cloud
billing account.
If you are a Google Cloud
user within an organization,
you'll need to have the Billing
Account Creator role in order
to perform this task.
If you are not a member of
the Google Cloud Organization
but instead are managing
your Google Cloud
resources using Projects, you
need no special permissions.
Get started by heading
into the Cloud Console.
You can start on your
Organization or any Project
homepage.
Then head to the Navigation
menu in the left-hand pane,
choose Billing, and then
click Manage Billing Accounts.
If you land in the
Billing Overview page,
like we did here, you can
navigate to Manage Billing
Accounts by expanding
the dropdown
list of Billing Accounts.
Click Create Account.
Give your account a name.
Choose your
Organization, if this
is applicable in
your case, and select
the country that corresponds
to your billing address.
This will determine your
payment options and currency.
Note, you cannot change the
country for a billing account
after it is created.
Click Continue.
Next, select an existing
Payments profile,
or create a new one.
A Payments profile stores your
payment instrument information
and defines how you pay for
charges across all of Google.
To use an existing
Payments profile,
you must have sign-up
and purchase or Admin
with all permissions for
the Payments profile.
Note that permissions
for the Payments profile
are set by visiting
pay.google.com and not using
the Google Cloud IAM service.
If creating a new
Payments profile,
you must indicate
your account type.
Select Business if this is
for a business, organization,
partnership, or
educational institution.
Otherwise, select Individual.
Note, the account type cannot be
changed after profile creation.
Then choose a payment method.
Check the documentation
for more information
on which payment methods are
available for your country.
Finally, enter your
payment method details.
Click Submit and Enable Billing.
Congratulations, you
can now link projects
to this billing account.
Note that by default, the person
who creates the Cloud Billing
account is a billing
account administrator
for the Cloud Billing account.
To learn more about
updating billing account
and Payments profile
settings after creation,
follow the link in
the description,
or head over to
the documentation
to check out more details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]